for complex news and first we feast I'm
Hanuman Welch and today we're gonna
learn how to elevate that persistent and
often misunderstood holiday mainstay
eggnog never serve that store-bought
cart and swill to your friends or family
not even that one uncle who calls
certain people oriental stepping up your
eggnog game is easier than you think the
tools you're going to need are a blender
a bowl and whisk the ingredients you're
going to need are eggs milk whole cream
sugar and a dash of nutmeg and my
personal favorite bourbon some recipes
call for cognac others call for brandy
I prefer bourbon because it pairs well
with eggs tastes great in holiday
cocktails and it also tastes great my
morning coffee
it's nice start by separating four egg
yolks easy way to do that is in a bowl
go ahead crack your egg right on the rim
here and you're gonna want it gonna yeah
you're gonna want to catch it
seriously hard-boiled let's let's just
start over
let's guys we'll just do it again once
you've got your four yolk separated
whisk them together in the bowl you're
gonna want ahead and purchase more than
four eggs just in case oh you're gonna
want to add two two ounces of milk
two ounces of bourbon at this point
you're gonna want to add one ounce of
heavy cream yeah you're gonna want to
add two ounces of bourbon it actually
nothing this looks nothing like the
pictures at the Bourbon store bought so
the eggnog for complex news I'm Hanuman
Welch time first we feast today we're
going to make some eggnog all you're
going to need is store-bought nog if
you're lactose intolerant
or from Williamsburg you're gonna need
some silk eggnog for the holidays and a
dash of nutmeg yeah I know
your mama's gonna need a refill it's not
eggnog it's just about the booze really
at the end of the day what you're gonna
want to do is combine your nog with your
brandy or cognac or your vodka or
whatever your girlfriend hasn't hid from
you this week and blend
- a nutmeg this is how we do white
Christmas in Los Angeles that's gonna
take shall we taste like my parents
still love me for more complex some more
holiday recipes and more keep it locked
right here to complex
first we feast we're holiday recipes and
more is fine spy